science
time
[Music]
I'm
having such a
touch
you okay
[Music]
oh explore
200 degrees
[Music]
more powerful than a locomotive
locomotive what are you an Old
Prospector
you can leave tall buildings in a single
bound
[Music]
single bound
you're Punk's charged your phone's
charged
you know what you really need like a
like a mic drop catchphrase after you do
some food I've been thinking about that
I would say what about what about this
that's why you don't mess with
electricity catch rage is obviously
aren't one of your superpowers and your
phone's charged well you think you can
do better
let there be light
to me
[Music]
how do I never mind
would you see when you see where their
boobies when you see nipples why are you
talking
we're gonna need more money wow you're
in there for like five minutes dude
we're very convincing
[Music]
him